[Music]
[Applause]
bring in uh Chris Sims a pro football D
live co-host in football night in
America H Robert Salah was trying to say
something nice about Zack Wilson how
would you feel if you're Zach listening
to that with your head coach well you
know there's there's not a whole lot to
say the reality is right now I mean it's
a disaster so I'm Zach I'm sure is very
you
know uh aware of the reality of the
situation it it's he's not good right
you know he's not playing good there's
no help I mean come on we're getting
ready for the Sunday Night Football game
and going through pregame stuff and we
already have a list of like a 100 plays
of like guy blown up blocking guy can't
block guy can't block guy can't get open
so it's a lot of issues but damn that
offense needs to do something because
they got no chance with the way they're
playing right now okay but explain this
to me Aaron Rogers goes down and the
entire offense implodes well I think the
I mean I like you know I think it's fair
to say we might have been a little ahead
of ourselves on that too went down and
like three out of the four plays looked
like crap so let's not forget about that
he had no time to do anything and they
were running slant and slant and slant
and slant and slant and it's just like
okay yeah that that ain't going to work
on a consistent basis you know so but
also
yes I mean would it be better with Aaron
roders certainly I don't think it'd be
like remarkably better though I don't
now he would be able to manage the game
and take the care of the ball and
probably get them in a few plays that
Zach Wilson's not capable of doing
because Rogers is the master at the on
the- Field General stuff right right but
still like they lost 15 to 10 last week
like if Rogers was playing could they
have won 16 to 15 yeah maybe they might
have lost 15 to 13 too they can't run
they can't protect and they only have
one receiver who's really a separation
receiver in gett Wilson and that's a
problem okay why are they adding Trevor
Simeon and why are they adding him now
as opposed to a couple of weeks ago I
yeah I that that I don't know now he was
a name that I I brought out pretty
quickly in the process he's been in the
West Coast offense so I knew that okay
you know from that standpoint he'll get
up to speed pretty quickly he's been in
a number of different West Coast offenes
two I think he's a guy that hey he's
played he's an insurance policy but he's
not this presence that is just going to
cause like everybody like oh play him
play him play him it it like takes away
from distraction a little bit and the
other thing here too Dan is Aaron Rogers
by all du accounts is going to be back
next year so what are they going to do
trade the farm for somebody that's
really damn good and then and then go oh
wait what do we do here we have Rogers
and somebody else let alone we know that
anybody really damn good is not
available for trade right now so you
know I think that's probably where it
ends up going back on Trevor Simeon what
if the Jets end up with a top five
pick oh I it's easy would you take a
quarterback I would 100% right you know
I'm I'm Hey listen I know I was you know
Zack Wilson right one Trevor uh Trevor
Lawrence too I'm wrong about that I've
been saying that I know that now I was
right about m j MC Jones and Trey Lance
and Justin Fields I'd like to point that
out too though right just to let you all
know right like it wasn't all but but
yes if I was them I've seen enough like
the most concerning thing to me about
Zach Wilson and he has had no help but
the end of week two when the game was 30
to1 that was the first or not the first
time but really a time where I went man
he just doesn't get it to be down 30 to1
to throw interceptions when the game was
over and you know put gasoline on the
fire of Zack Wilson stinks and just not
kind of play the game within the game
the politics of the game a little bit
that really spoke loud to me like Damn I
guess he just doesn't get it he ain't
ever gonna get it okay does Justin
Fields get it no no Justin Fields does
not get it Justin Fields is an athlete
who plays quarterback he's not a
quarterback who is a good athlete and
that's the way it should be but yeah I
know there's all this excuse making
everywhere and all that I mean I was
laughing last week watching one of the
sports networks tell me it was Justin
Fields it was the Bears were failing
Justin Fields as they were showing
highlights of people open all over the
field and I'm going wait are they
watching the same games I'm watching
here right so that was a little insane
but yes there's they they call plays in
the way that they're still managing him
and they don't trust him and then he
does not see the field very well he
watches the rush play after play after
play and wait a minute explain that yeah
explain like there's so many plays where
you look and you go wait what there's
people open over here and he's kind of
dancing around looking at who's coming
cuz he's going to get ready to run and
that's one of the biggest reasons he
takes a lot of sacks and why there's
missed people open and opportunities
downfield so that that is definitely
something that's a problem for this
Bears offense right now you got the
Bears hosting the Broncos yeah the
Broncos just lost by 50 and they're
favored in this game right okay right
that says something right A little it's
kind of crazy all right who do you like
in this game I like the Broncos okay I I
definitely the Broncos are a better
football team than the Bears you know
the the Broncos disaster last week
especially on the defensive side of the
ball like it's one of those where I'd
love to sit down with you and watch the
film and you just go what are they doing
here like I how many times are they
going to get burned by this same run
before they make an adjustment are they
ever going to touch a receiver or they
just going to let them all fly down the
field and just get up on the safeties in
point four seconds but Sean pton was
supposed to change all of this you know
Nathaniel Hackett had the worst coaching
job in NFL history I hear you I hear you
no listen it it don't look good on Shawn
Peyton right now either but the one
thing he can sell to his team is hey
they could have easily won week one and
week two right week one it was a a
nailbiter between the ra the Raiders
week two I mean they had Washington on
the ropes it was 21 to3 they were moving
the ball and there was a wideopen
receiver coming and Russell ran for some
reason and fumbled the ball and they
picked it up and the game was never the
same so there are some positives to
point out there and I'm going to bet on
Shawn Peyton and what I've seen over the
last 20 years from him that they come
back and bounce back and play tough and
win this football game talking to Chris
Sims pro football talk live co-host
football night in America his unbuttoned
podcast uh let me talk have you talk
about the the Dolphins offense is there
an offense that it reminds you
of well it's the
49ers except the 49ers do all the
motions and movements to enhance the Run
game and then that then enh helps their
pass game the Dolphins are like the vice
versa because of the weapons and the
team they have they've built it on let's
do all these motions and everything and
expose people through the pass game that
way and then we'll get people to play so
much pass defense that now we'll run the
ball and that'll be easy because
everybody scared as hell of us throwing
a deep to Waddle and Tyreek Hill but is
Mike McDaniel doing something different
that we haven't seen you know well I
think he's he's is like Shanahan he's
got a brilliant mind he's not afraid to
try new things and I can't tell you how
many coaches in football are afraid that
like I didn't nobody ever taught me that
so I don't know if I can make that guy
run the corner route and that guy run
the post route like whoa so they're very
conservative that way Shanahan McDaniel
McVey they go what this looks cool and I
I know defenses and I think this will
screw them over I'm going to try it even
though we've never seen this play before
that's where he's different and where I
always praise Shanahan is he could be a
defensive coordinator and and that's
where McDaniel is special is he can he
knows teams are playing me like this I
know the rules of their defense and now
I'm going to do some movements and
motions and things that are going to
expose some of the rules of their
defense and make it hard on them and
they're going to have to change it and
that's where I think it's you know
different than just about anything we've
ever seen plus you give Tyreek Hill a
running start it's like a CFL offense
and exactly right they they are Masters
at spreading you out horizontally and
then they get you spread out
horizontally and then they carve you up
vertically and they got quite the
formula working right now what have you
seen from Jordan love with four starts
in his uh pocket yeah a little little
inconsistent right but like definitely
some positive things to look at and go
hey I I'm a Believer in this Packer team
the defense is good you know if they can
get Aaron Jones and Christian Watson who
Christian Watson is one of the most game
breaker type receivers in football they
can get him healthy they could be
dangerous the one thing I really like
about love right it's not you know
efficient and surgical quite yet but
he's got great feel in the pocket and
unlike Rogers the last few years like
he's willing to push the ball down the
field and Pat the ball an extra time in
the pocket and go wait I see the guy
coming open for 25 yards I'm going to
I'm going to wait and let it let him you
know work and and I'm going to hit them
here and that's where they become a
little bit more dangerous where they're
running the ball and pretty creative in
that department and then when they drop
back to pass it's not look for the four
and five yard completion it's like no
let's look for Musgrave the tight end
down the middle for 20 or Jaden Reed for
a 20 yard out route and that's what I
really liked about Jordan love let alone
like you've seen he hasn't blinked in
the big moments it hasn't been perfect
but he doesn't look like he's like a
deer in the headlights as an NBC
employee you have the Chiefs and jets on
Sunday night any any intel on Taylor
Swift is there a Taylor Swift feature
coming up on football night in America
well I not that I know I don't think
there's a feature that might be one that
like is above my pay grade and they give
to Maria Taylor like so that could be
but we're getting all the rumors that
she's going to be there at the game and
that's a non- denial denial I well I
don't know if she
is she going to sit down with Taylor
Swift I don't think so I don't think
heard with Travis Kelce that I I feel
like Travis Kelce might be on someone's
interview docket but it certainly wasn't
mine you think there a couple Chris do
you think this is real you think this is
wow this this just in what makes you
think that Taylor Swift and Travis Kelce
well him Taylor Swift won like is the
most popular person in the world like
what what is she like gaining out of
Travis Kelce like there there's nothing
there where she's like well man I have
900 million followers I need 900 million
and 100,000 like what so I don't look at
it that way he's a star of stars in the
NFL and I think it organically happened
from what I even know from other people
kind of connected to the situation it
kind of just it happen so yeah you know
she lives in New York it's right across
the river you know she's in the East
Village or the West Village I know she's
somewhere down there so I would expect
to see her at the game if she's at the
game I can promise you NBC will have a
camera on her a lot through the night
that's for sure okay don't incorporate
Taylor Swift song titles into highlights
on Sunday night okay it was a one week
thing okay know I know I know I know
shake it off mat Dan Shake It Off I know
I know I know yeah I am never ever ever
ever having you back on the show again
damn is that right all because of that
good it's just a takeoff uh Before I Let
You Go your sep
10vp in the NFL is who it's hard not to
go with Tua right now I think that's
probably somebody I I look at right now
just what they're doing on the offensive
side of the ball who who else am I
missing here yeah oh or it's Christian
mcaffrey I I'd probably mcaffrey or or
Tua those would be the two I'd look at I
I worry about mcaffrey being overworked
but damn I mean he's been an Allstar in
all three games could you play
quarterback better than Zack Wilson this
weekend no probably not no no way
probably not if I gave you a
month I don't I don't think so I'd like
to think like yes but realistically it's
it's so hard
I mean like it's it should when you
haven't played for a while just look at
Deshawn Watson he's one of the the
better talents we've ever seen in the
history of the sport he went a long time
without playing and last week was the
first time we saw him where we went ah
that kind of looks like the old DeShaun
Watson so I'd say no let alone I'm 43
and I don't want to be hit anymore so
there's a lot of problems
there thank you Chris have a great week
all right Dan that's Chris Sim he's a
co-host with Mike Florio pro football
talk live that precedes our show and of
course contribute to football night
America